delia tiene más de 500 canciones en su
celular y desean estimar qué proporción
de canciones son interpretadas por
mujeres ella toma una muestra aleatoria
simple de 50 canciones de su teléfono y
encuentran que 20 de las canciones
muestreadas son interpretadas por
mujeres con base en esta muestra cuál de
los siguientes corresponden a un
intervalo del 99 por ciento de confianza
para la proporción de canciones en su
teléfono que son interpretadas por
mujeres así que como siempre pausa el
vídeo e intenta resolverlo por tu cuenta
bien ahora vamos a trabajarlo juntos por
aquí voy a poner a las 50 canciones que
tenemos en el celular de d elia y ella
está tratando de determinar la
proporción de canciones interpretadas
por mujeres no tiene tiempo de revisar
las 500 canciones para encontrar la
proporción poblacional pp así que decide
tomar una muestra de 50 canciones así
que en este caso n es igual a 50 y
determinar la proporción muestral la
cual denotamos con p sombrero y en este
caso nos dicen que es de 20 canciones
muestreadas es decir 20 de 50 lo cual se
observa es 0.4 y lo que desean es
construir un intervalo del 99 por ciento
de confianza antes de construir el
intervalo de confianza tenemos que
verificar que se cumplan las condiciones
requeridas por la técnica
así que antes de calcular este intervalo
tenemos que asegurarnos de que nuestra
distribución muestral no está
distorsionada por así decirlo para que
podamos construir con confianza el
intervalo de confianza la primera
condición es la siguiente tenemos que
verificar que en efecto la muestra sea
una muestra aleatoria pero eso lo
especifican por acá ella toma una
muestra aleatoria simple entonces esta
condición de aquí si se cumple la
siguiente condición implica suponer que
la distribución muestral de proporciones
se puede aproximar como una distribución
normal para esto debemos checar que en
la muestra tenemos al menos 10 éxitos y
al menos 10 fracasos pero aquí tenemos
20 éxitos y 50 menos 20 personas 30
fracasos porque esta condición también
se cumple finalmente la última condición
se denominan como prueba de independent
o regla de independencia o regla del 10%
si estás haciendo el muestreo con
reemplazo es decir escuchas una canción
verifica si la voz es femenina y las
regresas al archivo de canciones para
elegir otra canción entonces cada una de
las observaciones es realmente
independiente pero no sabemos eso de
hecho vamos a suponer que de elián no
hizo el muestreo con reemplazo cuando
tenemos un muestreo sin reemplazo
podemos suponer que las observaciones
son a grosso modo independientes si el
tamaño de la muestra no rebasa el 10% de
la población en este caso es exactamente
el 10% de la población así que él ya
apenas logra cumplir esta condición de
independencia habiendo considerado esto
veamos cómo construir el intervalo de
confianza este va a ser la proporción
muestral que es p sombrero más o menos
un cierto valor crítico que voy a llamar
setup estrella y este valor crítico está
determinado por el intervalo que
queremos el intervalo del 99% de
confianza ya esto lo vamos a multiplicar
por la desviación estándar de la
distribución muestral de proporciones la
cual desconocemos por lo que en lugar de
eso usaremos el error estándar de la
proporción muestral la cual en este caso
va a ser igual a la raíz cuadrada de
peso hombre que multiplica a 1 - p
sombrero ok y esto dividido entre
entre el tamaño de la muestra y esto
cuánto nos da este p sombrero ya vimos
que es 0.4 así que me quedaría 0.4 ya
esto le sumamos y le restamos este valor
z estrella que todavía no lo sabemos
pero en breve lo sacaremos usando la
tabla zeta ceta estrella y esto a su vez
lo voy a multiplicar por la raíz
cuadrada y que va a dentro de este
radical bueno me quedan 0.4 que va a
multiplicar a uno menos 0.4 lo cual es
0.6 y todo esto dividido entre 50 bien
ya podemos revisar estas opciones que
tenemos y esta de aquí y ésta de aquí
corresponden a lo que vamos calculando
por lo que solamente nos queda
determinar cuál
de estas dos incluye el valor crítico
adecuado
queremos incluir 1.96 errores estándar
por arriba y por debajo de la proporción
muestral o queremos incluir 2.576
errores estándar por arriba y por abajo
de la proporción muestral y la clave es
el nivel de confianza requerido del 99%
si tenemos un nivel de confianza del 99%
una manera de abordar esto es déjame
hacer un buen esbozo de la distribución
normal por acá así que si deseas un
nivel de confianza del 99% eso quiere
decir que quieres incluir este 99%
central del área debajo de la curva esta
área de aquí así que si esto es 99% este
pequeño pedazo de aquí tiene que ser de
0.5 por ciento y este de aquí también es
de 0.5 por ciento queremos el valor z
que nos dejan 0.5 por ciento arriba de
él por lo que de hecho va a ser 99.5 por
ciento
necesitamos buscar en la tabla esto es
porque la inmensa mayoría de las tablas
incluida la que aparece en el examen
apple de estadística indican el área que
se encuentra por debajo del valor z por
lo que también se incluye este pedazo de
aquí así que busquemos la teta
correspondiente al 99.5 por ciento en
nuestra tabla esta es nuestra tabla zeta
y veamos 99.1 va a hacer entre estos dos
valores que tenemos por acá esto es dos
puntos 52 puntos 57 o dos puntos 58
entre esos dos valores así que este de
aquí tiene que tomar un valor entre dos
puntos 57 y 2.58 de cualquier manera ya
tenemos suficiente información para
responder la pregunta definitivamente no
es esta opción de aquí porque 1.96 no
está entre dos puntos 57 y 2.58
otro caso 2.576 está efectivamente entre
2.57 y 2.58 por lo tanto esta es mi
opción correcta pero recordemos ya
construimos el intervalo de confianza
que tenemos aquí ahora bien qué es lo
que representa tener esta respuesta
bueno nos indica que si tomamos
repetidamente muestras de tamaño 50 para
las cuales usamos esta técnica de
cálculo del intervalo de confianza
entonces aproximadamente el 99 por
ciento de estos intervalos que hayamos
construido van a contener el valor real
del parámetro poblacional espero que
esto te haya sido útil nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo